hi everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina air bringing review of
this week's episode of arrow season 2
episode 8 state versus Queen so I'm not
always the biggest fan of court case I
mean it's not long orders it's not the
good wife this is not a few good men you
know I don't know three inhalers for
getting it always feels like it's just
kind of forced in there and it drags on
sometimes right you long and that's what
that's I thought about this episode I
thought it was starting off kind of slow
a little were doing one of those episode
right you know but then it got good yeah
you know I mean they mix up enough stuff
to just know keep everything fresh and
go and we got you know I guess let's
start off going going to the island
Josefa dr. Ivo he knows trying to find
out this trying to find this what is
this an arrowhead you know in the cave
that we find out that you know Oliver's
girlfriend at the present time seems to
have so ya know and it's the thing I
thought all the flashbacks were really
well done on this episode and I as well
i'm watching the episode i'm thinking
you know what a lot of these scenes are
so good that i'd almost kind of want a
full episode so really just kind of
flesh out that backstory right a bit
more because a lot of those those flash
books are really good and there's so
much going on i feel like you know
there's so much story to tell that it's
kind of a shame that's just kind of you
know limited to just however many
minutes in episode yeah the island stuff
sometimes just goes a little too fast i
think yeah it's two quick little rush
but it's good i'm gonna spend a lot of
time I mean I guess okay I guess this is
good to observer ebuddy guys probably
watch this you're like oh it's good to
the end so let's just let go to the end
man error is unloaded it's something
Trent his weekly trend in it like I said
the episode was little so cat you know
vertigo the actor who played it is from
fringe he's good but like you know count
vertigo is not the most interesting bad
guy all the people they've introduced
lower level so I mean he was fine but
I'm glad that kind of got rid of him
yeah then at the end well it is TV you
know we don't is that's true he could
come back this is the comic book which
leads us to the whole idea again if
you're watching us now about now you
know our reviews are spoilers so we are
gonna spoil the heck is episode so
Merlin Malcolm Merlyn is back from the
dead back from the dead with
dad we now know or were assuming that he
is part of the League of Assassins oh
yes she's worked with ratio cool yeah
and he uh he turned the tide of the
court case he he he basically you know I
don't know if he paid them off or just
kind of threatened the jury to con a no
go with and not guilty right verdict and
stuff which I kind of assumed something
here cuz I mean she got off pretty
easily oh yeah cuz even Oliver was like
he was shocked when Laurel was
interrogating her a heart he's like why
would I be upset about that like you did
you know you're doing your job are you
okay like it was very understanding this
episode he's trying to do the right
thing yet it just pulls him back in it
hasn't back in posing back in and going
back to Malcolm and stuff I thought it
was kind of interesting how he's kind of
back to kind of torture their mom yeah
you know what I mean basically I still
has her you know and is in the palm of
his hand and stuff and then like you
know we said we discover vertigo was
being funded by brother blood yeah which
is really cool I like that little twist
I thought that was Ben interesting going
back to what you're saying about you
know count vertigo kind of beam below to
your character and stuff i thought this
definitely made it a little cool because
then it makes it he's not the big six
isaiah and then of course we found out
secret identity of the young lady over
here Thea yes Malcolm she gon be that
was kind of a whammy you know it's like
yeah he's going to her choice and that's
the thing yeah we talked about this
before it just seemed like she was
taking up space they were just finding
things for her to do right so this
hopefully could be something a little
bit more interesting right and uh kind
of leads me to how i feel about Laurel
right I don't know how you feel right
now but like last season she played a
huge role yeah show this season I feel
like she's kind of just been in the back
a little bit like aside from like
developing an alcohol and drug addiction
stuff I feel like she has only had that
much to do yeah you know what i mean so
like i just feel like she's almost
taking up space right now yeah I think
that's the one with the show again it's
a good in too bad you know and talk
about this a little bit last week ago
i'm gonna compare a little bit to Game
of Thrones you know not saying it's on
that level but it is a big big world
it's a large ensembles I story to all
these guys like I want more Deathstroke
I won the war may have been that you
know I now I mean let's let's get into
some news this week casting news yeah we
know that one of racial goals not
you know one of his daughter you're not
a little fling with the lady age in
Machado those immature the comic books
is gonna be coming you know also being
played by another Katrina log another
you know Spartacus you know now we have
minus Katrina law we have WI Robinson so
more Spartacus cast members are coming
to the screen that's gonna happen I blew
this an episode 13 so how the 2014 which
makes you think that you know maybe all
the rumors about you know Isabel rochev
might be true that maybe he is Thalia
she could be taught yeah I mean she's
tough I mean I'm dulles this is so much
going on and then we know looking ahead
not next week's that's weeks
thanksgiving over here and then the week
after the december i think it's a
December fourth I believe I'm gonna get
while Barry Barry Barry Allen oh yeah
now how much are we gonna see I don't
you know really know it's right it could
just be buried just being buried I think
they released recently a news thing over
the news article they're talking about
how I think flash gonna get his own
standalone origin stories don't see him
on pilot so this might just be like
cases the actor is introduced him I
heard supposed took a three-episode arcs
I hope he's in at more than just one
episode so yeah we're gonna see him yeah
just just just crazy every week just
keeps building and building kind of
makes you wonder like you know that like
i said this is a good problem to have
you know every single week there's
something to look forward to be kind of
can't help but wonder how long is this
gonna last i'd like to think it could
last all season because every single
episode just kind of ends with this like
a you know mind blown moment you know so
but that's why i like the season has
been so good and so much fun right i was
gonna I know a lot of you been asking
about our like views like if we read the
comics before I read when the new 52 did
their whole relaunch whatever I wrote of
like probably five or six issues from
Green I read a little bit before the
whole relaunch took place if you know is
issuing his character is a lot different
the comics than he is your day are kind
of going the Bruce Wayne for sure i'll
repeat is a rich rich kid in the books
but he's not like you a field to shoot
yeah he's much more like screw the
government a little bit more you know
five other pants type of guy you know
what I mean and that's fun and I like
that but I think for the sake of TV I
like that change also yeah it's good
they kind of made him a little bit more
Bruce Wayne Ashiya have so bus there was
the sub let's not forget the submarine
that's writing forth right which had
something that could save the world and
I couldn't but wonder i was thinking
like could it now granted you know they
changed a lot of stuff for TV and stuff
like that so i thought about the Lazarus
Pit maybe
the idea of like the traditional idea
like the Lazarus Pit might single hope
the period too yeah so made me wonder
like what was on the ship could it be
maybe the Lazarus Pit we'll just you
know be turned into maybe like a serum
so they were developing some type of
drug to make Zack or soldier so yeah
perhaps I came it'll trying to that
somehow right so I mean yeah this could
save the world I don't know I mean is it
Sarah Sarah Sarah Sarah could be crazy
black and there could be crazy who knows
but this is I miss has been a great
season so far and it just getting this
journey we got a few more episodes left
until the big you know break for the
holidays so yeah this keeps going so
that's those are our views and her
thoughts on on this week's episode of
arrow you know I got don't forget next
week when i take a break back december
fourth for another review hopefully good
see some Barry Allen action so they
excite it's gonna be fun yeah so as
always you know come talk to us let us
know you think you can find us on think
here calm and also check us out on this
YouTube page here think hero pro talk to
dennis michael myself on twitter we're
at think hero i'm at griffin de and i'm
at mr. michael Alexis they can also find
us on Facebook that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans you know go ahead give
us a like subscribe like this video
share with your friends tweet it out
spread the words but how good arrow is
in other shows are you liking right now
so yeah we'll see you in a couple weeks
you